- We are back.
I'm here with Kaheer Suleman,
who is the co-founder and CTO of Maluuba,
and who is now a principal
research program manager at Microsoft.
And Jianfeng Gao, a research manager
at Microsoft Research Redmond.
They're going to talk to us today
about literate machines.
They will share with us a little bit
about the latest research in getting machines
to read with comprehension
and write like people do.
Welcome Kaheer and Jianfeng.
How are you doing?
- Happy to be here.
- Great.
Happy to be here as well.
- So I've studied MLP,
I've studied machine translation.
I don't know what machine reading comprehension is,
so why don't you start out
with describing what it actually is?
That way we can get a sense for what it is.
- So the groups here at Microsoft,
whether it's Maluuba or Redmond or Microsoft Asia,
we're working on this vision
of having neural networks
be able to take in large amounts of unstructured text
and then be able
to perform tasks with it.
And these tasks can be something
like question answering,
so we want to be able to really
comprehend the information that is there.
And you can almost break down reading comprehension
into these multiple levels of skills,
one being reasoning,
the other being knowledge representation.
How do we represent knowledge
about the world?
How do we represent
knowledge in the text?
And then finally extending
that beyond to common sense.
What is, how do we know
about everyday things in our lives?
And how do we then take that from text
and do something useful with it?
- I see.
Jianfeng?
- I can give you a bit of history.
Over the last 20 years we have tried to pass
large amounts of test data on web and dictionaries.
And at any point, entities and their relationships
to create the knowledge graph, as Kaheer said.
- Sure.
- But recently we hit a wall
in terms of performance,
by approaching it this way.
And do you know what the missing piece?
- No.
I mean, I remember doing something,
for example like word net,
and deep mind was like
an extension of word net
that sort of mapped all these entities.
But I always felt like, how are you
going to represent everything?
- That's one of the key issues.
And actually, when you have the critical
missing piece, the so-called semantic reasoning.
Put it this way.
If there wasn't an exact text stream
that matched the idea, you could not find the answer.
- I see.
- Quite often there are tons
of different ways of saying
how long a river is.
And remember, there's a key difference
between similar words and similar concepts.
That's why we resolve to neural networks
to relate the semantically similar concepts
and entities by mapping them
into a hidden semantic space
where semantically the data,
the concepts are paired together.
- So my question is, I understand
how deep mind would stop working
because it's looking
for like regular text,
and it doesn't find the exact text.
Or if the question is phrased
in a way it has never seen,
it's never going to be able
to pull the semantic meaning.
But my question to you is, that model
I understand how to code it, right.
I understand how to work it.
How are you using deep learning
to represent text without its task?
Because generally when we have text,
there is like a task.
I want you to find, I remember the first MLP thing is,
we have a bunch of emails from a disease outbreak,
and I need to find what the disease was and what died.
It was a specific task.
But with machine reading comprehension,
there's really no task, right?
- Well I mean the task, so if we're talking
about understanding word meanings,
we create this task based on this idea
that words are known,
their meaning is told by its neighbors,
so the words that are around it.
So we build these models that can predict words
around it, so that we can get word meanings.
But there is a task with reading comprehension.
- OK.
- It's a QA task.
So how do we test child comprehension?
We give them a passage, we give them questions,
and then we say answer them based on this passage.
And that's how we've been setting
up tasks for reading comprehension.
- So the main target or the main output of this
is we want it to consume all this text,
and we want to be able to ask it anything
about anything in any particular form.
Is that right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so how does it deal
with ambiguous questions?
That's the thing I have a hard time with.
For example, Dr. Grosz was talking about hey,
where are the 10 nearest pharmacies?
Which one is open?
How does it deal with context?
Can it do that?
Tell me about that word.
- This has something related
to the hidden semantic space.
In that space, all the language of different
explanations are what we represent using vectors.
- OK.
- In that hidden space.
That's the interesting thing
about this space.
If there's two test streams,
they are semantically similar,
so no matter how they are different from surface form
they will stick together
in that semantic space.
And that's the magic.
- And so this network is literally gluing
all of these things together in a way
that we maybe don't quite understand,
but seems to work.
- And that's why in most cases the most effective model
is trained by performing tasks,
not by remembering things.
- I see.
And that's a human feature.
So where is the state of the art
in this area right now?
Let's talk about, like, is it working?
- So, I mean, I think the biggest
and most interesting areas
that have seen improvement
recently are in the area of reasoning.
The ability to use something called
an attention model to figure out,
to learn, to look where
in the text semantically things
that are related to the question,
be able to combine these facts
that are in the text together.
Also, you know, we've made some progress
looking at QA in a different angle
as a generation task.
So where you model reasoning not
from the retrieval point of view,
where we are just answering a question,
you look at it from, how do we,
what's the mechanism
for generating the question
that led to the answer?
- Oh, I see.
- So these are kind of the areas
that I think have really seen
the biggest improvement.
But of course, I think some of the other areas
like knowledge representation and common sense,
there's still work to go.
- What about you?
Where is the state of the art for this?
- I agree with Kaheer, I can give you an example.
Recently we've developed a neural natural
reading comprehension called the Read
Net which has shown
a lot of promise.
The model uses the neural networks
to not only remember things,
but learn to perform real-world tasks
using knowledge such as question answering.
Actually, although we don't know
exactly how the human brain works,
this is a constant source
of inspiration for us.
For example, Read Net tries to mimic
the inference process of human readers.
Think about this.
When you read a document,
there's a question mark.
You always read a documents several times,
each time focusing on different portions
of the document
until a satisfied
answer is formed in your brain.
Our Read Network is just like that,
but in the neural space.
- So maybe, like I just barely started
understanding neural networks.
I remember learning neural networks,
but now that they're a lot deeper,
they can do a lot more,
I'm trying to understand,
how does it encode
that information?
- That's through training.
For example,
we use large amounts
of question-answer pairs
as a training aid,
to help the Read Net
to learn the models.
I'll give you an example.
If, for example, the model,
you give the model a question.
The model will try to form
an answer to the question
by leveraging the useful information
or relevant information
stored in its memory.
But in the case that such information
is missing in memory,
then the Read Net needs to learn to seek
and to store new information
by updating its memory
via the so-called
reinforcement memory.
So that neural network will be able
to answer the question next time.
- So for training, if I'm understanding
this right, you give it a lot of questions.
It creates a representation.
And then you ask it more questions
and more questions
and then it updates
its representation.
- Yes.
- What does that representation look like?
- So one of the things there's been some interesting
work is on visualizing these representations.
So if you could almost look at it like,
the way we have to look at it is the way
we visualize things
going on in the brain.
We have to, because what it really is,
is a large vector space
where certain things
get activated based on certain words.
That's what's happening, right, so you can look at it
like the way people look at FMRI.
So when certain words appear,
certain neurons get activated in the neural network,
just like what's
happening in the brain.
Certain regions of the brain get lit up,
and that's sort of what it really looks like.
And it could look different
at any different time of the network.
- I see.
What do these vectors look like?
I mean, when I'm asking a question, like I'm trying,
because I'm a programmer at heart.
When it comes down to it,
these theories are very nice.
But then we've got to type
something into a computer.
Like when it's coming in, what kind
of transformations are you doing
and then how do you actually get the thing
to spit out a reasonable answer?
Because it's not just a question
of getting information out,
but then it's got to write it out
in a way that a human can understand it.
- Yes.
So what happens is,
and Jianfeng can talk more
in detail about this,
is you start off from what we call
the symbolic space,
which is the words.
They get transformed
into a set of vectors.
These vectors then get transformed over
and over again by the neural network
that's doing the reasoning
as it updates to memory.
Then at the end, we transform it back by
making predictions based on the output words.
So we transform it back
to the symbolic space.
So now your answer is in the space
that you and I understand.
Internally, you know, these vectors
and different regions of this vector space
are going to get activated
when different words come in.
- I see.
Jianfeng.
- You know the neural space is just like your brain.
You can come up with an answer to a question.
I really don't know how you
generate the answer in your brain.
The brain is, in the neural network,
like a neural space.
So usually you take the question
from the symbolic space and map it in the neural space.
Now in the neural space,
that's where all these vectors are.
You generate an answer, in your brain.
Then you need to speak out
this generates the answer,
and then by transporting it
from the neural space
to the symbolic space,
so that people can understand it.
- I see.
So you're getting some real human input.
You put it through this washing machine
and this stuff happens there.
And then what it does is it goes backwards
out of the washing machine
and then it outputs a really, really good answer.
- Yes.
- So what are some real-world applications
of your research
that people are actually using?
- So one of the areas that we were looking at is,
how do we take the state-of-the-art
models in machine
reading comprehension,
and how do we put it to use
with something
that would actually help people?
And the first thing, and the thing
that came to my mind was, you know in your car,
you have that
400 page auto manual
and you probably have
never read it?
Yet, if your car gets in trouble,
all that information is there.
So the idea was, can we ingest large
documents like a help manual,
user guides, et cetera, and then be able to do
Q&A on this document?
- I see.
So next time I can't make my TV work,
I just feel the manual into the computer
and I ask the computer,
hey, how do I make this part of my TV work?
- Yes.
Or where is this in the TV
or why is this not happening?
Exactly.
- I see.
And is this a piece of software
that's out in production somewhere?
- It's in development.
- OK, I see.
I see.
So this is really cool.
What's next?
- I think, you know, the big area as I mentioned,
a couple areas was knowledge representation.
So while we've made strides in reasoning,
how do we represent,
how do we factor reasoning
from knowledge representation?
So that we can give it
any arbitrary amount of knowledge,
and the system can
then reason on that.
And then the other area that I think
is really key, is common sense reasoning.
Which is, you know, that people haven't,
people are working on it,
but we haven't really made
any major breakthroughs in this.
- How do you do that?
- The difficulty with this,
I would say the difficulty is that we are often working
in what we call a single modality
Whereas humans,
we experience everything
in many, many modalities.
We have sight, we have hearing,
we have text, we have all sorts of stuff
and we just we get common sense,
you and I, by experiencing it in the world.
But when we give it to this computer,
the computer can't experience the world.
And you know, text sometimes
is not only enough to learn.
And that's what makes it really, really difficult.
- I see.
So there's like a loss in fidelity
in just having things in text.
- Yes.
Because, and this is
because common sense is assumed, right?
When we write text, we assume through
the experience out in the world
that the common sense is already there,
that the reader is already
going to know about it.
So we just don't really write that.
We don't write, OK, the ball went up in the air.
The ball hit the ground.
Because we assume that you know when
you throw a ball in the air, the laws of physics apply.
- Sure.
I see.
Jianfeng, what's next?
- Following what Kaheer said,
that's also the reason why the current machine
reading comprehension tasks
are a little bit too simple
to develop common sense reasoning.
I will just give you example.
We have a data set.
In that data there's an assumption
that given the question,
the answer must be in the text.
Meaning that you don't need
any common sense reasoning.
If you read the text, you understand
text, you get the answer.
It's simplified saying, which would not encourage
the machine to learn common sense reasoning.
We need a more comprehensive
and challenging task for the machine
to learn common sense reasoning.
And we're working on that.
- You're saying more complex tasks than just,
here's a set of questions, get it out of this.
- Yes.
- It really comes down to,
you know, you can do this with QA,
but it really comes down
to what you're doing QA over
and what is the reasoning
and skills needed to answer the question?
If all I need to do is literally like do,
you know, search, find, then the models
And that's all I need to do
that's in this task,
then any model that we train
is only going to be as good as that.
It can only do find.
We need to build tasks that really
make common sense reasoning required,
or make knowledge representation required,
make complex reasoning required.
- So is that the area?
Because I mean, because the first thing
I thought is machine
reading comprehension,
there's tons of assumptions that I made.
Like for example, when I understand stuff
in text I'm making mental models
that I can use later to do other stuff,
and learn other things.
But the tasks that you are describing
right now seem very narrow.
What are some things that we're doing in order
to make it have that common sense?
- For example, we tried to introduce a
concept called the long-term memory into model.
Think about how people
generate our common sense.
It is through years and years
of experiencing the world.
And then what you learned in the past
can be useful in the future to solve new tasks.
That's where the capability is lacking
in the current machine learning,
machine comprehension tasks.
- Awesome.
Well, believe it or not, we're out of time.
I wish we had tons more time.
I tell you, this was
really interesting.
Thank you, Kaheer and Jianfeng
for your insights into machine reading comprehension.